what I was thinking is I was watching
this about what an art it is to do what
you do but do you want us to notice
sound while we're watching a movie or do
not want us to know this sound yeah I
think that's a great question actually
no we want you to notice the story the
characters and you know people say a lot
sometimes to me oh it must ruin the
movie for you because you must just be
thinking about sound and conscious of
sound but no I am NOT unless it's like
really really good and something
different maybe but or really really bad
like where's the sound or why is it in
that speaker but because you wanted to
work with this you want it to work so
well we're not doing sound for sound
sake right I'm sure there are a lot of
70s
we don't do sound for sound sake like
something like the radio but we're doing
it with picture and you want it to work
with the picture so well that you don't
realize what we're doing you know just
like we don't think hair and makeup or
production design or you just want to
get pulled into the story and that's
what that's what our job is and and
Walter over the time that you've been
working in this genre
have you seen not not just the technical
advances but how the sound has been
regarded as part of the filmmaking
process integral to it rather than
perhaps incidentals some directors may
think well I think it's always been a
challenge because of budget problems and
limitations the the budget for
post-production sound on films is a
relatively small proportion and when
other things happen during the shooting
the budget for sound will inevitably
diminish so we're always struggling
you're the squeeze in the toothpaste
yeah yeah it but it depends on
ultimately on the director and the
directors interest somebody like Orson
Welles who came from a radio theater
background brought with him when he did
Citizen Kane and all of his subsequent
films he was fascinated with the power
of sound and the spatialization of sound
which had been almost completely ignored
up to that point the
before Citizen Kane people just depended
on the picture to give you a sense of
the space and what wells did that broke
new ground was to also involve sound in
that spatialization so and Hitchcock was
was very fascinated by sound so it it
depends on the on the the filmmakers
themselves to be the forces that drive
this Bobette I'll ask both you and Karen
how you came to this film Bobette you've
got an academic background as well so
talk a little bit about that and then
we'll get to some of the issues like
five screens full of credits so actually
this started when I was a graduate
student at USC in the Peter stark
producing program in my fall semester
the first semester Jay Roach who at that
time was my film producing film
production teacher gave one lecture on
sound design and it was the Elephant Man
with Alan splat was the sound designer
with David Lynch and it just blew my
ears wide open that you could create
such a inner life revealed of this
monster who so hated his life he felt
his loneliness in the first reels and
then you brought in the Samuel Barber
adagio as he developed in confidence and
and love of life and we saw the
immersion and the revelation of dignity
and that just blew my mind so anyway I
went on to create a course on sound and
storytelling did it around the world
Pixar asked me to do it there and who
should be in my audience but Gary writes
to him who's won seven Oscars for sound
design and I was like oh my god it's
Gary Wright strum and I went up to him
and I said mr. Wright strim if you don't
agree and he said I love this he said
let's go to lunch and so I got very
cheeky and I said you know how come you
guys haven't done a documentary it was
it's about time and he said look we're
very busy and he said I would take a
long time and at that time Clips
clearances was the big you know Bugaboo
which midge can discuss you know would
be too expensive and but I had been
working with USC law
Clin Entertainment Law Clinic on fair
use with Jack Lerner and Michael
Donaldson and I'd been actually to
Capitol Hill
you know testifying before the librarian
of Congress and he said you know but if
you do it I'll back you and I'll
introduce you to all the major people
George Lucas Spielberg Walter Murch Ben
Burtt but he said you have to go to
Mitch Causton at USC and that's how we
started it and Karen I had previously
done a documentary that was focused on a
different part of the industry I did a
documentary a producer documentary
called double-dare about Hollywood stunt
women and Babette knew that I had been
her student at USC and so she was aware
of my background and interest in that
and I think you know describe the
project to me I had a strong memory of
having seen visions of light which had
come out and theaters at a time that he
rarely saw documentary in theaters and
so the idea of exploring that other half
of the cinematic experience was
appealing to me and I got involved with
she and Midge to produce it you've come
from USC as well
you're you've been hearing as you worked
on this I'm sure all the stories about
how sound was orphaned how it was
sidelined how it was kind of secondary
or incidental is it different now both
for young people who are coming into the
industry and for the regard that it's
given at this most important influential
university program I mean I can't speak
to the industry overall just my own
experience but like I know like at USC
it's incredibly valued you know like we
we have a class where everyone kind of
comes together and like we divide up
into different roles and you know the
sound is celebrated just as much as the
other crafts in that and I actually was
able to take that class with Mitch at
USC and and that was kind of how I got
connected to the whole film so were you
then intimidated as you were editing
this film about and with a woman who'd
been your professor and people you would
end up working with I'm sure well
I wasn't intimidated with midge I mean
midge and I had just had such a you know
great I mean incredible teacher and you
know and it was great working with with
Bob ad and Karen and everyone and I I
was very intimidated by making being an
editor for a film about everyone in the
film history I I mean in time I think
you know we got a rhythm but going in it
was definitely like wow this is this is
gonna be seen by film industry people
and they don't know if it's edited so
one thing that struck me not only
looking at this panel but looking at the
film was that perhaps more than other
elements of filmmaking there's pretty
much more equal division of labor
between men and women a lot of women in
this part of the industry so perhaps
each of you can talk about that from
your point of view why that's the case
and and when we get to David to talk
about whether you're seeing that now in
the academic setting as well just I know
that one of the reasons that I ended up
well it's C III when I started in film
it was that I would start I came out of
film school and I was gonna do I was
gonna be a sound I was I worked
apprentice editor assistant editor
picture and then a friend Dan Hegeman
called me up and said midge no none of
these Union guys he was working at
chameleon sound he said none of the
Union guys will touch 16-millimeter and
so that's how he started working he said
you can cut the diet the effects and
I'll cut the dialogue and and so I I
became a dialogue editor and what I
noticed was that there are a lot more
women who cut a cut dialogue instead of
effects and at the time now dialogue
editors are also Co supervisors so
that's a great thing but there do seem
to be more women the women that I work
with we'd say sometimes well and they
see it like a sewing circle because it's
very in it's very detailed work and so
in your dinosaurs brain surgery well
it's kind of surgery and so there seem
to be a lot more women and then usually
dialogue interests weren't supervisors
but there were people like like Walter
did would hire patchak's and you know
every time you added in a movie it's in
my pap was the was the supervising
editor and so and I know
see see halls in the audience I think
it's our earlier and you know Richard
Anderson hired her and so they were but
when but see see I remember telling me
when she was working at Paramount and
she looked around it was kay Rose who's
in the movie was the first woman to win
an Academy Award and her daughter Vicki
Samson was also in the movie and that
was it and really I can still count on
my hand how many women were cutting
effects and just recently someone came
to me and say Oh midge you should meet
so-and-so she's a girl and she's got any
effects I mean a girl of probably
40-something oh yeah so it's there is
kind of this division of labor
hopefully it's none you know I don't
know if it's changed that much that
would be interesting you told me Bob at
and then Karen well this story what's
difficult to tell is a documentary
because you you know people say oh it's
an abstract story about sound good luck
and we wanted to bring in characters and
show the create an emotional arc to the
story of course and as we got into it
and we have like 90 interviews 500 hours
and all these transcripts we knew that
we had this great story starting with
our philosopher king Walter and then Ben
with all of his innovation of Star Wars
and Gary and but we knew we had to bring
in women as they had come along and been
mentored by particularly Walter and Ben
and Gary and there's a whole new
generation of women CC hall or a
Hirschberg Annabel mer all these great
women Terry Dorman so we finally after
wrestling with how do we bring in new
faces diversity other stories we came up
with the graphic design of the circle of
talent which was the line of Terry
Dorman's and then Walter had talked
about the orchestra image and we
combined those as two as the device by
which we could tell many stories and
bring in many new faces and and really
show the complexity and range of tasks
that are in the sound industry I mean a
lot of people in the Academy don't seem
to know why there are two Oscars for
sound and and why are there so many
credits for sound now and that was our
way of really celebrating that as well
as describing with the why I know
someone said that maybe the
presented is is more women heavy than
then in the movie then it might be
actually in the industry and I do think
that we made it a point to be sure and
feature women because unfortunately too
often that doesn't happen and so as the
famous sewing saying goes if you can see
it you can be it we wanted people to see
it
so some appreciation for the panel and
thanks to all of you for coming